wait a minute
psionics are you telling me that you
built a supersonic acrobatic rocket
powered battle car from a DeLorean
that's right starting next week you'll
be able to drive the iconic DeLorean
from Back to the Future film the movie
series iconic time-traveling car is
being released on October 21st that date
isn't random October 21st 2015 is the
day that Marty McFly visits in Back to
the Future Part 2 so if you haven't
taken the time to order a hoverboard you
might want to get around to that
so Back to the Future car will run use
two bucks and will also come with the
iconic flame tire tracks which can be
equipped as a rocket trail and in case
you were curious the wheels do lift up
like they do in the movies when you're
doing aerials one Reddit user asked a
similar question and psionics responded
with the resounding you bet your ass it
does Roger you're getting quite a bit of
new content this month a new DLC pack is
due out this week that adds content
inspired by the game's predecessor
supersonic acrobatic rocket powered
battle cars it's also adding Halloween
themed items that you'll be able to
unlock but only for a limited time for
someone who just recently bought a king
sized Reese's Cup this will literally be
these best two dollars I've spent all
year for all of your supersonic
acrobatic rocket powered battle car news
if you go to GameSpot